A binary variable is one that has
a yes or a no, a 1 or a 0 or a true or
false type of value associated with it.
Therefore, those binary
problems would be
identifying if an email is spam or not.
On the other hand, non-binary variables
are one's that are categorical.
Meaning there are values
that take on names, or
labels such as red, green, blue,
or small, medium and large.
The non binary problems would be,
what land cover type is a pixel
from a satellite image?
As well as,
what color shirt looks best on me?
When looking at the land
cover classification problem,
there are typically more than two land
cover types, such as grass, trees,
agriculture, water, urban, etc.
We can claim this as non binary then.
But for the shirt problem, there are
obviously more than two colors we can
choose from making this
a non-binary problem.